as violent crime continues its spike in
new york competing visions for the city
battle it out
president biden gets concerned about the
economy and the covettlab league theory
cover-up is exploding into public view
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you
gotten a vpn yet visit expressvpn.com
slash ben well
you may have noticed that in april alone
consumer prices increased
by 4.2 that is the biggest bump since
there's higher fuel prices and higher
food prices and higher construction
costs and higher housing prices
inflation is here you may have noticed
it in all of the prices of
all of your goods like all of them so
here's the question have you protected
your savings and your investments
because inflation eats away at savings
what you ought to be doing is taking at
least a little bit of your money and you
ought to be diversifying
into precious metals if you haven't
reached out to my friends at birch gold
today to diversify part of your ira or
401k into a precious metals high array
go ahead and do it today text ben 247 47
47 get a free information kit
i'm protecting your savings with gold i
buy gold from birch gold because they
have an a plus rating with the better
business bureau countless five star
reviews
over ten thousand happy customers talk
to them have them help you safeguard
your investments
make sure you ask them all your
questions get all your answers and then
talk to my friends over at birch gold
text ben
47 4747 when you make a purchase before
june 30th
birch gold will send you a signed copy
of my book how to destroy america in
three easy steps for free
while supplies last again text bench 47
47 47 protect your savings today and
again when you text
my name to 47 47 47 we take ben to 47 47
47 to make a purchase before june 30th
birch gold will send you a signed copy
of my last book how to destroy america
in three easy steps for free while
supplies last
alrighty so a couple of nights ago
there's a big debate
in new york city between all the mayoral
candidates and there are a few aspects
of this that are amusing
aspect number one seven of the eight
candidates said they actively did not
want bill de blasio's endorsement
for the earthly which is a hell of a
referendum on the guy who's the sitting
mayor of new york city that's how
unpopular bill de blasio is
inside his own city he has aspirations
to run for governor or senator
dude couldn't win an election for
dogcatcher today in new york city
because nobody likes him
and the reason is because the ideas of
leftism have run
headlong into the brick wall of reality
in new york city
and so while the media continue to focus
in on the inspirational wildlife figures
of new york the people like jamal bowman
and alexander ocasio-cortez
and bill de blasio the reality says
something different
but the reality suggests is that when it
comes to actual policy
new yorkers are beginning to turn more
toward the rudy giuliani few
sort of left-leaning social policy and
right-leaning crime policy that
characterized new york city
throughout the giuliani and bloomberg
administrations why well because it
worked in new york you know it doesn't
work in new york
anything that the democrats have been
doing there for the last 10 years
okay what they've been doing there for
the for for the last decade has wrecked
the city particularly the last five
and everybody knows this so the media
continued to trot around following
around aoc i just want to point out the
mentality of the alexander ocasio-cortez
left
it is pretty astonishing so there are a
couple of things that are worth noting
about the alexander ocasio-cortez
left mentality number one they truly
believe
that your money is their money and that
they have no obligation to do moral
things with their money
this was an undercover story in the in
the major media but alexander
ocasio-cortez
she recently posted photographs of her
grandmother's squalid living conditions
in puerto rico and blamed president
trump for the situation
she put on on twitter just over a week
ago my grandmother fell ill
i went to puerto rico to see her my
first time in a year because of covid
this is her home hurricane maria relief
hasn't arrived trump blocked relief
dollars for puerto rico people are being
forced to flee ancestral homes and
developers
are taking them and then she tweeted out
a picture of her
grandmother's roof which appears to be
collapsing in places
later she amended the tone of her
comments 45 minutes later her
grandmother was doing okay
now the reason that she said that is
because everybody pointed out
that alexander ocasio-cortez has an
annual salary of 174 thousand dollars
she has no children she doesn't have
tremendously high expenses except for
the tesla that she recently released and
so everybody online was like you know
alexandria before you blame trump for
your grandmother's squalid living
conditions your words
you might want to like check your wallet
i check your pocketbook
see here's one of the things about
conservatism conservatism suggests
that there are a series of overlapping
circles in terms of responsibility
okay when it comes to people who are in
your immediate family and people who you
are close to
you have chief responsibility in taking
care of them
then if that doesn't work you go to your
local community and then if that doesn't
work you go to the larger community
to maybe a an actual local government
then you go to your state community and
then maybe at the very end you get to
the federal government but the first
line of defense
against difficulty in life is your
immediate circle and so
if my grandmother is having financial
trouble then i step in
if i have the ability to do so and this
is what most people do
the fact that alexander that it never
even occurred to her my grandmother's
roof
is falling apart maybe i should do
something about that instead of
releasing that tesla
maybe i should instead at least you know
an electric honda or something
for like one-third the cost and send the
extra over to grandma the fact that
apparently never occurred to her
is just indicative of a particular
mindset which is it is never my
responsibility to do anything it is
everybody else's responsibility
to do everything it's the government's
responsibility to do
everything i mean it's kind of an
incredible
indicator of exactly where this
mentality lies and it's true for
national politics too
if there's a problem in my immediate
community the problem must lie with a
broader societal issue
as opposed to what can i do about it
today
and what can people do what what can
people with agency do to fix their own
problems okay so
that is point number one point number
two is alexander ocasio's
okaza cortez's view of crime so
yesterday
she did this press her and it was kind
of amazing she was standing directly
next to chuck schumer
the senate majority leader and she was
calling for more funding for
mental health which fine i'm on board
with that i think one of the great
tragedies
of public policy the last 60 years is
the attempt to federalize
all mental health and
institutionalization issues it started
under the jfk administration and moved
forward
with states shirking their duties and
this has led to a tremendous rise in
homeless problem
over the course of the last few decades
okay but alexander ocasio-cortez
is talking about crime and here she is
explaining that the real problem the
real reason
why we have too much crime is because we
are building too many jails
let's check out how this works if we
want to reduce violent crime
if we want to reduce the number of
people in our jails the answer
is to stop building more of them the
answer is to make sure that we actually
build more hospitals
we pay organizers we get people mental
health care
and overall health care employment etc
it's to support communities not throw
them away
okay look at the body language on chuck
schumer there chuck schumer is like i
want to crawl in a hole and die
he's sitting right next to her she says
because here's the thing she's in a city
where crime is skyrocketing and her
solution is build fewer jails
as someone on twitter pointed out this
is akin to saying
if you want fewer sick people build
fewer hospitals you build the jails to
hold the criminals you don't build the
jails and then there's an upsurge in
demand for criminality that's not how
any of that works
okay but this sort of perverse thinking
that my problems are everybody else's
problems
and my immediate family's problems don't
fall on me they fall on the government
more broadly
and when it comes to criminality that is
a broader societal problem
where the government is not supposed to
step in and solve it instead it's a
broader societal problem that we just
blame on everything else
that sort of mentality has crippled new
york and continues to new york
and you can see it play out in the new
york mayoral race or if you look at the
polls right now
the two people at the top of the heap in
terms of the candidates
are the two most conservative democrats
in the race we'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about
your sleep quality so
let's be real about this if you have
kids or if you are stressed maybe your
sleep quality isn't the best but when
you get on that mattress you can't be
worried about the mattress the mattress
has to be the one factor that allows you
to drift off into a nice
a nice evening's sleep helix sleep does
that for me why well because
my helix sleep mattress it's
personalized to me it is made just for
me
they give you a two minute sleep quiz
and then they make a mattress that is
perfect for you
everybody's unique helix knows that they
have several different mattress models
to choose from they've got soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
that are great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot they even have a helix
plus mattress for plus size folks
so if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress
you're matched to the mattress comes
right to your doorship for free
you don't ever need to go to a mattress
store again helix is indeed awesome but
you don't need to take my word for it
helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020 by both gq
and wired magazine
just head on over to helixsleep.com take
their two minutes sleep quiz they will
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you
the best sleep of your life if you have
a 10 year warranty you get to try it out
for a hundred nights risk free so you
really have nothing to lose
they'll pick it up for you if you don't
love it i promise you're going to it is
an awesome mattress helix is offering up
to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
that is helixsleep.com for the special
deal okay so all this sort of idiocy has
had serious consequences
for new york according to joel siegel
who's the managing editor of spectrum
news dc
nypd now says the number of shootings in
may of 2021
jumped 73 compared to may 2020
173 shootings in may versus 100 last may
and that was on top of a 63
increase in may 2020 versus may of 2019
there were 61 shootings in new york in
may 2019.
today may 2021 173
shootings in new york that is the result
of a
of an administration that has decided
they are not going to police crime
they're going to release criminals back
onto the street
it's an administration that has decided
not to enforce the law that is going to
allow black lives matter rioters to run
roughshod through the center of new york
city this has
downstream effect in terms of criminals
believing they can get away with
anything
i am fully convinced by the way that the
uptick in hate crimes that you have seen
against jews
is fully connected with law
enforcement's inability or unwillingness
in areas around the country to actually
police
when policing goes away crime spikes and
that is true with regard to all types of
crime
including hate crimes okay that is a
reversal of a trend by the way
this this reverse it is incredible how
there's been this secular trend
meaning a widespread trend for the last
two decades
in terms of lowering crime rates
basically from 1994 all the way until
crime rates dropped precipitously like a
stone the reason for that is because
people in major cities started taking
policing seriously rudy giuliani was
elected in new york which reardon was
elected in los angeles you started to
see
all sorts of conservative policies
attempted with regard to crime
and shockingly crime dropped right these
are this was the days when joe biden
used to talk about super predators
and used to back crime bills and then
thanks to barack obama's administration
and the rise of
wildlife crazy people like bill de
blasio and eric garcetti and in major
cities around the country
crime rates started to rise again
because policy is indeed connected
with human behavior and you know he's
starting to realize this the people of
new york
because as it turns out what the polling
data shows in new york right now
is that the people at the top of the
heap in polling in new york
are the most conservative candidates
there is no progressive near the top of
the heap
according to usa today in what could be
the most consequential mayoral elections
in the city's recent history
a host of democratic candidates in a
tightly contested race are vying to
become the big apple's next mayor
eight major democrats are making their
final bids two new york city voters in a
campaign that has touched on a variety
of challenges facing the city
led to a diverse list of candidates and
featured plenty of zoom calls
the leading contenders are andrew yang
who is still seizing on the energy
around his 2020
democratic presidential run i know
andrew yang because he was
generous enough to do an interview with
the show i think he's a really good guy
i
disagree with him with regard to
universal basic income
which has been part of his pitch but his
main pitch has been i am not an
unreasonable crazy person
his main pitch has been we need to get
corporations back into the city we need
to get jobs back into the city and
we need to give the police the resources
necessary in order to shut down crime
eric adams a former nypd officer zeroed
in on public safety that's been his main
pitch
and then trailing the pack is catherine
garcia who's received a bunch of big
name endorsements from the new york
daily news but continues to trail in the
polling
because she is just not far right enough
the republicans in the race are not
competitive because one they're
republican and two
because they're not the sort of rudy
giuliani quote-unquote moderate
republican
that did well in new york for so long
but yang and adams look a lot more like
ed koch
who is the sort of gruff and evonkular
mayor of new york
starting in the late 1970s who converted
from being a radical
left bella abzug progressive into being
the sort of
conservative style democrats who govern
new york city for a while
these are those type of democrats this
is this is
leftism being rejected in places like
new york city because leftism has failed
in places like new york city
so it was fascinating the other night
they had this big debate and the people
who came off the worst by far
were the people who were the most wildly
to the left and the people who came off
the best
were people like adams and people like
andrew yang now the reason this makes a
difference is because
what happens in new york can happen
nationally and people
like to say that the democrats want to
take california national that's true
they also want to take new york national
but they don't want to take the style of
democratic governance
of michael bloomberg national bloomer
graham for the for the presidency on the
democratic side of the aisle and
received basically no support
joe biden seems to want to govern that
way at times during his campaign but
then he's run to the radical left he
looks a lot more
like aoc or like jamal bowman or like
bernie sanders than he does like the joe
biden that people thought they were
going to get when they elected him
so what happens in new york is a good
indicator as to what is going to happen
nationally
meaning there will be a backlash there
will be a conservative backlash if it's
happening in new york it can happen
anywhere
so andrew yang has been facing a lot of
this stuff down so yesterday for example
he was walking around
at a parked slo a park slope event and
uh he was
shouted down by people screaming to uh
to defund the cops
you can see people trailing him saying
hedge fund mayor
okay this is why yang is going to do
well in new york
but again he has no history in elected
politics and if he doesn't win the
mayoral race he's going to come in a
close second
they have ranked choice voting in new
york which means that i'm i'm kind of a
fan of rank choice voting to be honest
with
ranked choice voting works is that if
you vote for one of the lower down
candidates number one
on your ballot and then you vote for
yang too if the lower down candidate
doesn't finish in the top couple of
candidates
that person's votes are eliminated and
then your second choice becomes your
first choice
and they just keep doing this until
somebody wins okay so
yang right now is running in the top two
with eric adams eric adams of course
is a former cop okay so yang and adams
went at each other but the more telling
attacks were the ones that were
put out against adams and yang for being
too conservative
which is why they're winning it's why
they're doing well in new york this
can't be overstated
new yorkers are seeing the results of
the policies they chose
and they are not liking the results of
the policies they chose and they are
reacting to the policies they chose by
moving in a different direction
democrats had better be wary they had
better be wary
new york is a one-party city and they
are still moving to the right wing of
the democratic party we'll get to that
in just
one second first let's talk about the
fact that if your business is growing
you need better employees you need
people who are going to upgrade
your brand of doing business zip
recruiter is the way to go
right now you can try zip recruiter for
free at ziprecruiter.com
dailywire zip recruiter doesn't wait for
great candidates to find you
ziprecruiter will find them for you
when you post a job on zip recruiter it
gets sent out to over 100 top job sites
with just one click to increase your
chances
of reaching top talent then zip
recorder's powerful matching technology
scans thousands of resumes to find
people with the right skills and
experience for your job and actively
invites them to apply so you get
qualified candidates fast no wonder four
out of five employers who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the very first day we are constantly
using zip recruiter to find great
candidates
for our jobs it's one of the reasons we
found kelly kelly is fantastic
not only does she do amazing work
keeping everything around the office
running and humming but also she shoots
alligators in her spare time
start finding great candidates that's
true by the way when you try
ziprecruiter for free
you can find great candidates today just
go to this exclusive web address
zippercrew.com dailywire once again that
is ziprecruiter.com d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e
zip recruiter is indeed the smartest way
to hire alrighty so
some examples from the mayoral debate
the other night
so scott stringer who is one of these
also ran candidates
he was expected to be more of a
competitor in this particular race he
was the new york city
comptroller but then he was hit with a
sort of sexual harassment accusation
by a former political ally he denies the
allegations but he's been trailing
in the polls he went after
andrew yang and he said you know it
seems to me like you're a republican
that is not going to work i mean really
this is not a and yang just kind of was
like okay
it's kind of amazing as your consultants
have told you time and time again
they admit you're an empty vessel and i
actually don't think you're an empty
vessel i think you're
a republican who continues to focus on
the issues that will not bring back the
economy
in fact what you're focusing on things
like casinos and governors island
you're focusing on tick-tock houses in
the midst of a housing crisis
and what i'm saying to you today is
there is a budget crisis but it's a
budget crisis
that with six billion dollars in federal
stimulus money more money for the
foundation aid coming from albany
the next mayor must have the experience
on day one who could manage
closing the out yeah budget gaps okay
well this is going nowhere for stringer
because he attacks yang as a as a
tick-tock influencer guy okay first of
all in new york
everybody's a tech talking influencer
but second of all attacking yang is a
republican it ain't gonna do much
okay meanwhile maya wiley who is the
most wild-eyed of the of the left
candidates
on the board right she's a long-time
msnbc contributor
she worked with the naacp legal defense
fund as well as the aclu and served as
council to build de blasio which
yeah that's a resume that is not going
to resonate in a time when bill de
blasio is like the most hated person in
new york
she went after she went after eric adams
right
the way that she went after eric adams
is quite amusing so eric adams is a
former police officer and eric adams has
talked about the fact that he wants to
carry a gun
and he also wants to make sure that
off-duty police officers can carry a gun
in order to crack down on crime
this goes very poorly for maya wiley mr
adams has said he's carried a gun to
church he's asked off-duty officers to
carry guns to church
he said he will carry a gun as mayor and
maybe even ditches detail
eric isn't this the wrong message to
send our kids we're telling not to pick
up the guns
okay and the way he responded was i've
used my gun in order to stop crime off
duty
and he mentioned people who'd been
victimized by crime in the city
which is the reason why he's in really
good shape eric adams
again he's a retired former captain in
nypd
and he is running on a platform that
includes stepped up policing not stepped
down policing
the whole defund the police movement the
blm the police are the bad guys
all cops are bastards routine that is
not playing in new york city
you guys you're reaping the whirlwind
and you're not feeling it because these
people are registered democrats
when you elect ed koch democrats as
opposed to bill de blasio democrats that
indicates that he see change is
happening
in places like new york city meanwhile
yang himself slammed eric adams the the
battle in new york is is also sort of
internal so yang is going after eric
adams he says that eric adams has a
corruption problem which is kind of true
he is under investigation
i think three separate investigations
actually for corruption issues
eric we all know that you've been
investigated for corruption
everywhere you've gone city state even
barack obama's department of justice
investigated you you've achieved the
rare trifecta of corruption
investigations
is that really what we want in the next
mayor do you think you're going to enter
enter city hall it's going to be
different we all know it's going to be
exactly the same that's why so many
people on the stage
don't want you to be mayor okay so here
here's the
bottom line issue i'm putting aside all
the sort of fireworks that happened on
the stage the other night
right now americans are going to have a
choice do they want
the bill de blasioization of america or
do they want the
rhonda santa claus of america do they
want to make california more like new
york or make california
more like florida and or make america
more like florida
right the the idea of making america
more like new york new york is trying to
be more like florida now
new york is picking up why because
people are leaving new york for florida
the numbers are astonishing there are a
huge number of people who are snowbirds
who are now taking
their part-time residency in new york
and they're just moving it right down to
florida
you're seeing an influx of people from
the northeast and that is because of the
governing style in new york
if they hope to keep people they're
going to have to stop raising taxes
they're going to have to start backing
cops they're going to have to start
backing private property rights again
they're gonna have to start appealing to
the business sensibilities of hedge
funds that are
in the city but can easily move i know
several people who are working at hedge
funds who have moved their entire
businesses
down to florida i was meeting with the
mayor of miami yesterday he was talking
about the huge number of businesses that
have been moving from new york
to miami specifically because miami is a
friendly business climate and because
they're not going to shun business down
here in in florida
even new yorkers are getting to
recognize this and this bodes really
really poorly for democrats going
forward
it's not going to bode well for them
especially because again joe biden is
pursuing
the new yorkification of america not the
floridization
of america speaking of which look at
look at the way that the biden
administration is approaching economics
so yesterday gensake again making the
case we need to radically raise
corporate tax rates new york has tried
to do this kind of stuff you know what
happens
businesses relocate how bad is the
corporate tax rate proposal being put
forward by the bible administration it's
so bad they're trying to cudgel
literally every western country into
imitating their tax proposals
just so they can avoid the consequences
of their own tax proposals because
if you force people into a choice
between organizing in the united states
and organizing abroad
and if they can save money organizing
abroad they'll organize abroad
the united states knows this and so joe
biden is trying to force all of these
other countries
into setting a baseline tax rate so that
businesses don't move out of the united
states
if you have to do that your economic
policy sucks but here is john sackey
pushing that economic policy yesterday
anyway
he believes that we can should continue
to look at raising the corporate rate
that is a way to pay for a range of
ideas he's got a lot of ideas out there
a lot of bold proposals including that
aren't a part of this infrastructure
negotiation
and he continues to believe that
corporations can pay more unless you
think corporations shouldn't pay any tax
at all and we'll leave that to
to others to to speak to uh then
there should be a way to find a path to
agreement okay well i don't believe the
corporations should pay any tax at all
all that money gets passed on to
employees or in prices
that's all double tax money all of it
okay in just one second we'll get to
more of the
economic proposals of the biden
administration which continue to quash
economic
growth first let us talk about the
greatest gift you can give
somebody i mean the best gift the gift
that comes from the heart
i'm talking about steak indeed summer is
almost here that means father's day is
just around the corner omaha steaks
isn't just steak okay it's the best
steak
actually sent me a kosher steak a couple
years ago i still dream about this thing
unbelievable steak
guaranteed visit omahastakes.com keyword
shapiro order the get out and grill
assortment today
send dad more than just a gift send him
an experience he'll love and can share
with you
go to type shapiro in the search bar in
order to have the get out and grill
assortment it includes 20 entrees he's
guaranteed to love like ultra juicy
burgers plump chicken breasts
sides desserts and four 10 oz of
butchers cut new york strips
these strips are aged 30 days and why is
that important because age equals
tenderness plus
get four free new york strip burgers
with your order these are ultra lean
they pack a bold intense flavor for a
limited time you get four free new york
strip burgers with your order that is
omahasteaks.com
keyword shapiro i mean imagine your dad
opening up a box of omaha steaks for
father's day
you know how happy he's going to be the
happiest he has been since the day you
were born that's how good omaha steaks
are go check them out
right now omahastakes.com keyword
shapiro to get that special deal
today all right so the biden economic
plans they suck and joe biden is
beginning to realize they suck and that
the suckage of the economic plans has
actual consequences for his political
future
right here so there's data that came out
yesterday and it showed that hourly
compensation
is soaring and the reason that it's
soaring is because no one is going back
to work
it is almost impossible to get people to
go back to their jobs okay
when hourly compensation source you know
what happens to prices prices go up as
well
and when prices go up your savings are
worth less
and when your savings are worth less
this makes you poorer okay so
for the people who get those higher
compensation jobs
not terrible for everybody who has
savings not great and for people
who are not getting a raise also not
great
all of this is because in the short term
the body administration is blowing money
into the economy
in the long term what's going to happen
is economic stagnation as i talked about
yesterday
it's not just that you're going to get
inflation which is an ill
but even if the inflation levels off
you're going to get economic stagnation
and
biden is admitting as much he's
admitting that we're going to have like
1.8
growth for the next 10 years that sucks
those numbers are bad
and the reason for that is because when
you suck money out of the system
with a vacuum and then you blow it back
into the system
via a bunch of redistributionist
programs that get eaten up by the
bureaucracy
you're removing the productivity from
the economy
it is the reason you have not seen job
growth recover at the pace that you
would like to see
there's also a reason why joe biden is
calling lawrence summers the former
secretary of the treasury
under bill clinton according to the
washington post president biden recently
called
former treasury secretary larry summers
a democrat who's been openly critical of
his economic agenda to acknowledge
summers concerns and ask him to explain
his objections according to three people
with knowledge of the private exchange
biden made the call as the white house
is weighing critical decisions on the
economy
including how much and whether to trim a
far-reaching infrastructure plan
in response to republican demands my
conversation also unfolded against a
backdrop of warnings from summers and
others that biden's spending plans
present a risk of inflation and an
overheating economy
the white house has downplayed the
extent of the threat posed by inflation
arguing it will be transitory and
manageable
but in recent months summers has engaged
in increasingly bitter disagreements
with white house aides
summers has been warning that biden's
1.9 trillion stimulus package is way too
big
and will overheat the economy spurring
inflation that could prove hard for the
federal reserve to control
white house officials keep dismissing
this they're frustrated that he keeps
talking about it in the first place
apparently the call occurred late last
month but that doesn't mean that biden
is taking his foot
off the gas of course not keep on
keeping on
this is pop star never stop never
spending okay so energy secretary
jennifer granholm she came out yesterday
said we're not going to negotiate
forever on infrastructure we're just
going to ram
forward our program right here the
president really does believe very
strongly that the current tax structure
is skewed and he wants to rebalance it
in favor of
the middle class the working class and
to close
loopholes that allow corporations to
offshore
and to get away in many cases with not
paying any income taxes and that's not
fair either so there are other ways of
of skinning the cat and that's part of
this negotiation
but ultimately we cannot just sit and
negotiate forever we have to get
to an end okay what if your economic
policies suck because the jobless
numbers just came in
here are the jobless numbers in may the
united states added 559 000 jobs in may
now that would be good except we missed
my 750 000 jobs
last month and we missed by a hundred
thousand jobs the month before
the expectations going into this
economic report
671 thousand jobs so they missed by
again a hundred
thousand jobs again a hundred thousand
jobs
these are not good economic numbers
these are not the numbers that joe biden
needs
and they're not the numbers america
needs coming out of an artificially
induced economic
coma the fact
that that they're trying to blow money
into the economy and that it is not
working
is demonstrative of the reality which is
that when you threaten business
when you tell them you're gonna raise
the corporate tax rates when you talk
about making that
retroactive which frankly i don't even
know how that's constitutional
retroactive taxation they're talking
about making the corporate tax increase
retroactive so that you can't escape it
because they know that if they make it
proactive
there will be a stock market hit
immediately but if you make it proactive
that you're about to raise the corporate
tax rate
and that it doesn't have retroactive
effects then people are going to start
shifting their money out of corporate
stocks for example because they know the
corporations are going to get hit
if you make it retroactive then you say
okay well it's already priced in
but the fact that that the biden
administration keeps on missing
is fairly incredible because it's so hot
i mean
this it's the broad side of the barn
here guys all you have to do is get out
of the damned way but you can't get out
of the damned way
because your policy prescriptions are
not in line with reality just like aoc's
policy prescriptions in new york are not
in line with reality
and so new yorkers are beginning to turn
towards something that doesn't look like
aoc
they're moving away from bill de blasio
americans are going to look at the biden
economic agenda the biden crime agenda
the biden racial agenda the biden
foreign policy agenda they're going to
start moving away from it
i'm i'm fairly confident i mean i've
said this before if republicans don't
win back the house in 2022
given what is on their side the um
honestly every every member of the
republican house should lose their job
if the republicans cannot win back
the house in 2022 this is
these are bad numbers guys i'm sorry but
000 jobs in may with 650 000 jobs
expected those are bad there's three
straight months of missing on jobs
okay again what we are seeing also
averagely average hourly earnings
continue to surge two percent
the reason for that because people
aren't re-entering the workforce there's
high demand for labor and low supply of
labor so the prices are rising
this could lead to increased price
inflation at a time of economic
stagnation
or it could just be economic stagnation
for a long time either way ain't nothing
good happening because of the biden
economic agenda
okay in just a second we're going to get
into all of the
new information that is emerging
regarding the cover-up of the covet
lab leak theory that should have been
the main theory going forward
since early last year we'll get to that
in just one second first
can thieves really steal your home title
take it from this thief who stole over
150 home titles and was sentenced to 25
years in prison
this right here this right here it's why
you need home title lock nobody thinks
that i can take their house and borrow
against the house no no i have title
insurance for that
no it's in my name or he would have to
get some special document they would
call me you know
nobody's calling you after i've stolen
the title
barred against it or sold the property
or done whatever i've done with it
it's 60 to 90 days even figure out that
that they're the victim of this crime
you know by that point you start getting
foreclosure notices and you realize
you've got four mortgages on your house
not only that you don't even own your
home anymore it's not even in your name
i mean that sounds like a pretty good
case for getting home title lock today
head on over to hometitlelock.com
register your address to see if you're
already a victim
and enter a code radio for 30 free days
of protection that's code radio at home
title lock.com protect your most
valuable asset your home title
if ain't gonna just drive up in a truck
and pull your home away what they are
going to do is steal your home title and
then use it to take out
credit against your home title and leave
you in debt stick you with the bill
protect yourself with home title
lock.com today use code radio for 30
free days
of protection okay in just one second
we'll get to the continuing
implosion of the cover-up of the covet
lab leak theory vanity fair believe it
or not has a great piece on this today
first there is no threat like that of a
corrupt authoritarian government
and a corrupt authoritarian
institutional structure when your own
society begins exhibiting the
power-hungry controlling cult like signs
of authoritarianism it's time to stand
up and i have a book
that is here to do just that it's here
to help you stand up against all the
woke authoritarians
in your life in institutional power in
my new book the authoritarian moment
i help you understand how our culture
got to this point how you can fight
you're feeling it right you're feeling
it from your corporate bosses you feel
it in the educational sphere you're
hearing it every time you turn
on the media your values are going to be
rejected and you're going to be
extirpated from american society for
those values by the institutions that
you patronize the institutions you trust
and the ones that you work with
you need to stand up to it the
authoritarian moment is about how these
institutions got hijacked
and how we take the institutions back
the authoritarian moment today
now available for pre-order at amazon
barnes and noble or any other
major bookseller also also we have a
brand new
debunked audio episode that is coming
out tomorrow so make sure to
continue to tune in for that all about
joe biden's covet lies you've been told
that joe biden was a truth teller on
covet
yeah not so much so make sure you check
out debunked this weekend
the audio version of our beautiful video
podcast by the way you should check out
the actual video the videos are
beautiful looking documentary style you
can go to subscribe today
and you get them with a daily wire
subscription otherwise make sure to
check out the debunked audio
tomorrow because it really is quite good
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
by the way quick note on this economic
report the labor force participation
rate
went down this month down okay it should
be precisely the opposite right the
economy is getting back into full swing
you should be going back to work but
when you pay people to stay home they
don't go back to work
people have a bunch of money that the
government's stuffed in their pockets
they ain't going back to work they're
trying to spend the money but there
ain't the supply to keep up with the
demand
that's how you get inflation more
dollars chasing fewer goods but
in the long run is that price inflation
going to last well it depends are people
going to continue to take out debt and
blow it into the economy
probably not when the man ain't there
you're just gonna end up with prolonged
stagnation
well done once again for the team biden
for team biden just
amazing stuff no matter how many times
their economic theories prove fraudulent
and
complete failures no matter how many
times they suck money out of the
american economy
and then blow it back in in the wrong
places we're still going to pretend like
they know what they're doing
it's fairly incredible that the geniuses
who sit at the top of government
the people who can't tie their own
shoelaces or properly eat soup
these people are going to run the
economy better than you know how to run
your own business all right meanwhile
fascinating new article by katherine
eben in vanity fair
titled the lab leak theory inside the
fight to uncover coveted 19's origins
throughout 2020 the notion that the
novel coronavirus leaked from a lab was
off-limits those who dared to push for
transparency
say toxic politics and hidden agendas
kept us in the dark yeah no bleep
and some of us have been saying this for
quite a while i mean tom cotton
got beat around by the media and they
were just beating cuddling around the
ears
how dare he point out that this thing
probably leaked
from a lab it was just terrible and it's
amazing how they continue to downplay
the lab league theory by the way
i mean anthony fauci is like the worst
on this he's just terrible at this so
anthony fauci yesterday he was asked
about how we even get to the bottom of
the lab league theory and he was like
well the key is the key is
you gotta be really nice to china if
you're really nice to china that'll
really i think that'll really
don't be accusatory be nice to them
here's anthony fauci saying things that
make no sense as per his usual
arrangement
obviously you want openness and
cooperation
one of the ways you can get it is don't
be accusatory
try to get both a forensic a scientific
and an investigational approach i think
the accusatory part about it is only
going to get them to pull back
even more we've got to do it in a
combination of diplomacy
scientific forensic investigation and do
it in a way that the people
of good faith not who want to do blame
not to be i love how he's like we don't
want people who want to do blame around
here we can't have people who wanted to
blame
that would be terrible they might blame
me
you know where that's going right i mean
the people who have been most accusatory
are the ones who've been most accurate
so far
dr fauci and then watch like fatching's
like trust
trust people like me but then he's asked
about the lab leak theory and he's like
what if i just completely
mischaracterize the lab lake theory
entirely so i can dismiss it here he was
on cnn yesterday he's just
this guy needed to be fired months ago i
don't remember what's in that redacted
but there i mean the idea i think
is quite far-fetched that the chinese
deliberately engineered something so
that they could kill themselves
as well as other people uh i i think
that's a bit far out john
okay no one was making the argument as
far as i'm aware that trying to
militarize the virus
just to release it on an unsuspecting
world it's called a leak
lab leak theory elite from a lab
this is the one you should trust on the
captain science over here
meanwhile the nih director was doing the
same thing yesterday downplaying the
investigate it's not important
why do we even need to know how this
thing originated
we have to have a full-scale
congressional investigation into why
300 droogs invaded the capitol building
and then were immediately removed 400
people were arrested
and the process of government went went
on we need to have a full-scale
investigation
but the release of a virus that's killed
three million people worldwide including
six hundred thousand americans why do we
need to know where that came from
says the head of the nih i agree we need
to get to the bottom of this but gosh
you and i just spent a whole bunch of
minutes here
talking about some issue that we need to
get an answer to
and meanwhile people are still dying
from covet 19 and we didn't even talk
about the ways to get to an end to this
with vaccines
so please could we have a bit more of
the focus on how we're going to save
lives
while we're talking about how this all
started amazing
amazing okay so what actually happened
here in terms of silencing the
lab leak theory according to this vanity
fair piece gillis damenov is a data
scientist with the bank of new zealand
in auckland
he was diagnosed with asperger's
syndrome 10 days ago 10 years ago and
believes it gives him a professional
advantage i'm very good at finding
patterns in data when other people see
nothing he says
early last spring as cities worldwide
were shutting down to halt the spread of
covenant 19
deminoff 52 began reading up on the
origins of sars
clover ii the virus that causes the
disease the prevailing theory was that
it had jumped from bats to some other
species before making the leap to humans
at a market in china where some of the
earliest cases appeared in late 2019.
the juanan wholesale market in the city
of wuhan is a complex of markets selling
seafood
meat fruit and vegetables a handful of
vendors sold live wild animals a
possible source of the virus
that wasn't the only theory though wuhan
is also home to china's foremost
coronavirus research laboratory housing
one of the world's largest collections
of bat samples and bad virus strains
the wuhan institute of virology's lead
coronavirus researcher xi jing li
was among the first to identify
horseshoe bats as natural reservoirs for
cyrus kovet the virus that sparked an
outbreak in 2002 killing 774 people and
sickening more than 8 000 globally
after tsar's bath became a major subject
of study for virologists around the
world and she
became known in china as batwoman for
her fearless exploration of their caves
to collect samples
more recently she and her colleagues at
the wiv have performed high profile
experiments that made pathogens more
infectious
such research known as gain of function
has generated heated controversy among
virologists
to some people it seems natural to ask
whether the virus causing the global
pandemic
had somehow leaked from one of the wiv's
labs a possibility she has strenuously
denied
on february 19 2020 the lancet among the
most respected and influential medical
journals in the world published a
statement
that roundly rejected the lab leak
hypothesis effectively casting it as a
xenophobic cousin to climate change
nihilism and anti-vaxxism
signed by 27 scientists the statement
expressed quote solidarity with all
scientists and health professionals in
china and asserted we stand together to
strongly condemn conspiracy theories
suggesting that covet 19 does not have a
natural origin
the lancet statement effectively ended
the debate over cover 19's origins
before it began
to guilt dim enough follow following
along from the sidelines it was as if
everything had been nailed to the church
as if it had been nailed to the church
doors
establishing the natural origin theory
as orthodoxy everyone had to follow it
everyone was intimidated
that set the tone that statement struck
them enough is totally non-scientific
he began searching for patterns in the
available data it wasn't long before he
spotted one
china's laboratories were said to be
airtight with safety practices
equivalent to those in the u.s and other
developed countries
but dub enough soon discovered there had
been four incidents of sars related lab
breaches since 2004
two occurring at a top lab in beijing
due to overcrowding there a live sars
virus that had been improperly
deactivated
had been moved to a refrigerator in a
corridor a grad student then examined it
in the electron microscope room and
sparked an outbreak
domino published his findings in a
medium post titled the good the bad and
the ugly a review of tsar's lab escapes
by then he'd begun with working with
another armchair investigator raldolph
de maestro
a laboratory project director based in
paris who had previously studied and
worked in china
de mester was busily debunking the
notion that the wuhan institute of
virology was a laboratory at all in fact
the wiv housed numerous laboratories
that worked on coronaviruses
only one of them has the highest
biosafety protocol bsl4 in which
researchers must wear full body
pressurized suits with independent
oxygen
others are designated bl3 and even bsl2
roughly as secure as an american
dentist's office
having connected online deminoff and
demestra began assembling a
comprehensive list of research labs in
china
as they posted their findings on twitter
they were soon joined by others around
the world
some were cutting-edge scientists at
prestigious research institutes others
were scientists and
science enthusiasts at times it seemed
the only other people entertaining the
lab league theory were crackpots or
political hacks hoping to wield kova 19
as a cudgel against china president
trump's former political adviser steve
bannon for instance
joined forces with an exiled chinese
billionaire named gautwangui
to fuel claims that china had developed
the disease as a bioweapon and unleashed
it down the world
with disreputable right-wing nuts on one
side of them and scornful experts on the
other
the researchers often felt as if they
were on their own in the wilderness
working on the world's most urgent
mystery
they weren't alone when trump himself
loaded the lab leak hypothesis last
april
his divisiveness and lack of credibility
made things more not less challenging
for those
seeking the truth the researchers are
doing better research than the us
government says david asher
a former senior investigator under
contract to the state department the
question is why
that is the question the question is
what trump was saying the question is
what was the scientific community doing
for a full year for a full year
according to vanity fair it's all about
trump in the wake of the lancet
statement
under the cloud of donald trump's toxic
racism which contributed to an alarming
wave of anti-asian violence in the u.s
one possible answer to this
all-important question remained largely
off limits until the spring of 2021.
behind closed doors however national
security and public health experts and
officials
across a range of departments in the
executive branch were locked in a
high-stakes battle
over what could and couldn't be
investigated and made public according
to vanity fair
a months-long vanity fair investigation
interviews with more than 40 people a
review of hundreds of pages of us
government documents including internal
memos
meeting minutes and email correspondents
found that conflicts of interest
stemming in part from large government
grants supporting controversial virology
research
hampered the us investigation into covet
19's origin at every step
in one state department meeting
officials seeking to demand transparency
from the chinese government
say they were explicitly told by
colleagues not to explore
the woohan institute of virology's gain
and function research because it would
bring unwelcome attention
to u.s government funding of it
i mean this is bombshell kind of stuff
right that the state department was
actively telling people
do not investigate where this came from
because it might expose the fact that
the u.s state department has been
providing support via channels
to wiv's gain and function research and
wiv
released this thing accidentally so
instead it was important to cover up
china's involvement and also you can
always just blame it on trump's toxic
racism absolutely
in an internal memo obtained by vanity
fair thomas dennano former acting
assistant secretary of the state
department's bureau of arms control
verification and compliance wrote that
staff from two bureaus his own
and the bureau of international security
and nonproliferation warned leaders
within his bureau
not to pursue an investigation into the
origin of covet 19
because it would open a can of worms if
it continued
so don't investigate apparently
according to vanity fair in late march
former cdc director robert redfield
received death threats from fellow
scientists
after telling cnn he believed covert 19
had originated in a lab
i was threatened and ostracized because
i proposed another hypothesis redfield
told vanity fair
i expected it from politicians i didn't
expect it from science
i mean it's amazing dr richard ebright
board of governors
professor of chemistry and chemical
biology at rutgers said that from the
very first reports of a novel bat
related coronavirus outbreak in muhan it
took many nanoseconds or a picosecond to
consider a link
to the wiv only two other labs in the
world and galveston texas and chapel
hill north carolina were doing similar
research
it's not a dozen cities he said it's
three places then came the revelation
that the lancet statement was not only
signed but organized by as you a
zoologist named peter dashik
you may remember peter dasrich from our
episode a couple of days ago about dr
anthony fauci's emails dashik sent vouch
an email thanking him
for killing the rumors of gain of
function research being responsible for
this
so apparently that lancet statement
rejecting the covet
lab leak theory as racist was organized
by dashik
who has repackaged u.s government grants
and allocated them to facilities
conducting gain of function research
among them the wiv itself david ascher
now senior fellow at the hudson
institute
ran the state department's day-to-day
covenant origins inquiry
he said it soon became clear there is a
huge gain of function bureaucracy inside
the federal government
on may 26th the steady crescendo of
questions led president biden to release
a statement acknowledging the
intelligence community had coalesced
around two likely scenarios and
announced he'd asked for a more
definitive conclusion within 90 days
in the words of david feith former
deputy assistant secretary of state in
the east asia bureau the story of why
parts of the us government were not as
curious as many of us think they should
have been
is a hugely important one
so again there was consistent pressure
inside the us government
not to investigate this stuff
according to vanity fair on december 9
2020 roughly a dozen state department
employees from four different bureaus
gathered in a conference room in foggy
bottom to discuss
an upcoming fact-finding mission to
wuhan organized in part by the who
the group agreed on the need to press
china to allow a thorough credible and
transparent investigation
the conversation then turned to a more
sensitive question what should the us
government say publicly about the wuhan
institute of vorology
a small group within the state
department's arms control verification
and compliance bureau had been studying
the wiv for months they had acquired a
classified intelligence suggesting three
wiv researchers conducted
gain of function experiments and then
fell ill in autumn 2019.
as officials at the meeting discussed
what they should share with the public
they were advised by christopher park
director of the state department's
biological policy staff in the bureau of
international security and
nonproliferation
not to say anything that would point to
the us government's own role in gain of
function research
some of the attendees were absolutely
floored said an official familiar with
the proceedings that someone in the us
government could make an
argument that was so nakedly against
transparency in light of the unfolding
catastrophe was shocking and disturbing
park who in 2017 had been involved in
lifting a us government moratorium
on funding for gain of function research
was not the only official to warn the
state department investigators against
digging in sensitive places as the group
probed the lab-league scenario among
other possibilities its members were
repeatedly advised not to open a
pandora's box
said four former state department
officials interviewed by vanity fair the
admonitions
smelled like a cover-up said to nano and
i wasn't going to be a part of it
park said i'm skeptical that people
genuinely felt they were being
discouraged from presenting facts
he added that he was simply arguing it's
making an enormous and unjustifiable
leap to suggest that research of that
kind meant something untoward
is going on again this looks
very much like a cover-up and it looks
like a cover-up that was politically
motivated by bureaucrats inside the
government and media outside the
government bureaucrats inside protecting
their own asses because they were
involved in funding of gain and function
research in china that could have led to
the creation and then leaking of coven
19.
and a media willing to not investigate
not cover this stuff because the reality
is
all of this information was available at
the earliest date and the media were
complicit in covering it up
the media were too busy asking joe biden
about his cat
by the way they continue to be too busy
generally asking you know the biden
administration still has not been asked
serious questions by anyone other than
peter ducey
about the wuhan lab leak theory and the
cover-up
i mean it's fairly impressive i will
admit the media's performance on all of
this
instead they're like what you know the
right wing is focused on the why aren't
they focused on their own performance
well because if you cover up
the greatest biological scandal in
modern history
and you do so for political purposes and
you have no curiosity about it
that's kind of damning of you as an
institution in the media and certainly
damning of our public health bureaucracy
the experts
who are too busy covering their own
asses to be truthful about where
covenant 19 came from
even though it killed 600 000 americans
pretty incredible stuff and good for the
folks at vanity fair for late but
late is better than ever it's an
incredible story you should go check it
out over at vanity fair
because it really is telling what it
means when bureaucrats run the systems
bureaucrats should not be running
america's systems alrighty
we'll be back here later today with an
additional hour of content first
you cannot forget to end your week by
checking out the andrew clavin show
drew's show is every friday he's got an
exciting evening planned for you head on
over to dailywire.com this evening at 7
pm eastern 6 pm central tune in
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wydowski
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin